Is the ketogenic diet critical for bladder cancer?
Typically, no.
I don't know.
The person asks this question, I don't know.
What we tested you on is the cause or the dietary driver of your cancer.
But certainly, even if you've been following that well and your cancer is growing,
there's certainly nothing wrong with trying a different diet and going on, you know, ketogenic is,
I wouldn't say it's necessarily a radical diet, but it's a much more difficult diet to follow.
But it's certainly nothing wrong with going on.
Nobody's going to be injured by going on a ketogenic diet.
The only thing that I would say is if we found that your cancer is driven by proteins,
typically a ketogenic diet is going to be high in protein.
So you do our risky, you know, that.
But again, if your cancer is growing and you want to make some changes,
cancer can morph and change, and sometimes it's good to try a different diet like that
and give it a try for a month and see if there's any shrinkage of the cancer,
because cancer is constantly trying to morph and change its fuel source.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with trying to ketogenic diet if your cancer is going the wrong way.